force
as thus determined since it is conceived
as force
or as reflected into itself is one side
of its notion but
posited as a substantial extreme and
moreover with the expressed character of
a one
the subsistence of the unfolded matters
outside of force is thus precluded
and is something other than force since
it is necessary that force itself be the
subsistence or that it express
itself its expression presents itself in
this wise
that the said other approaches it and
solicits it
but as a matter of fact since its
expression is necessary
what is posited as another essence is in
force itself
we must retract the assertion that force
is posited as a one
and that its essence is to express
itself as an other which approaches it
externally
force is rather itself this universal
medium
in which the moment subsistence matters
or in other words
force has expressed itself
and what was supposed to be something
else soliciting it
is really force itself it exists
therefore now is the medium of the
unfolded matters
but equally essentially it has the form
of the supersession of the subsisting
matters
or is essentially a one consequently
this oneness since force is
posited as the medium of the matters is
now something other than force
which has this its essence outside of it
but since force must of necessity be
this oneness which it is not yet
posited as being this other approaches
it soliciting it to reflect into itself
in other words force supersedes its
expression
but in fact force is itself this
reflectedness into self or this
supersession of the expression the
one-sidedness in the form in which it
appeared
that is as an other vanishes force
is this other itself it is force
that is driven back into itself
in section 137 we're going to play out
this idea of force
a bit more we're beginning from what
hegel calls the notion of force
and you know we've been using this term
force
in itself or force reflected into itself
pushed back into itself force
per se force proper and then thinking
about expression is sort of like well
that's what force does
or or that's you know just something
that flows out of it we're going to see
that expression is something really
integral to force
but we're going to begin by saying well
the notion of force
is really about force as force
so as something reflected into itself as
a
unity as as a one and force
is in some way expressed
onto these indifferent matters which
constitutes some sort of other to force
they are not
force itself they are something that
force acts upon
something that's there outside of force
that force then
can intersect with you might say now
what we're going to be doing in this
section is realizing that that point of
view is
actually one-sided and mistaken
and that we have to go on to a more
adequate point of view so let's see how
this happens he says
we have this this character of a one
of a unity to force and then it's it's
uh
expressing itself onto these unfolded
matters
um there's something other than force
and
he says since it's necessary that force
itself be this subsistence this this
existence this substantiality of those
matters
or that it express itself its expression
presents itself in this wise that the
other approaches it and
i should put approach here approaches it
and solicits it so the the
other the the matters themselves have a
kind of
receptivity or an aptness for
force to be exercised upon them and you
know we could think about this in terms
of all different types of force
objects that that you know have are
affected by gravity which is one of the
examples
that hegel is going to use later on
why are they affected by gravity it has
to do with something that is of the
nature of those different
unities those different objects those
different independent things
namely they have mass right that
solicits
the action hegel says of the force
upon them or the binding capacity of the
force the determination that's going to
happen
through this force so he says
um now because its expression is
necessary
why is its expression necessary well
it's necessary
in two ways really it's being
necessitated in part
by this other that is
approaching it and soliciting it you
might say
that force is being in a certain way not
just solicited but provoked something is
coming forward and saying all right what
do you got
act upon me make me do something make me
relate to something make me think
something right
but there's a deeper thing to hear as
well
if you don't have action or expression
literally in german um this expression
is
oyster externalization being made
into something that you can actually
observe something that
is is out there not just in there right
this is the outer this is the inner
if you don't have that then you don't
actually have force
because force is forced precisely
by not just hanging by itself like a
wallflower at the dance
waiting for somebody to come and ask it
and even turning all of
its potential dance partners down but
because it actually gets out there and
does something
so it's necessary for force to
to externalize or to express itself
if that's the case then there's some
implications here
that means that the notion of force
has now been expanded it no longer just
includes force
as force but just as equally force
as expression so he goes on and he says
what's posited as another essence is in
force
itself this is all within force
we must retract the assertion that force
is posited as a one and then its essence
is to express
itself as an other so this relationship
between
one and other now is being modified to a
certain extent which
approaches it externally force is rather
itself this universal media
force is just as much as universal
medium in which the matters
have their subsistence as it is
something
outside of them and you might say
ready to be externalized upon them or
externalized within them
so he says force is this universal
medium in which the moments subsist as
matters or in other words
force has expressed itself force has
externalized itself force has unfolded
itself
from its interiority into exteriority
what was supposed to be something else
soliciting
is really force itself so this other
turns out as well to be force
this is a very important transition
point because what this means
is that we thought that there was
something outside of the scope of force
that force
could act upon right so something
outside of it ontologically
that then force could interact with in
in reality but the reality has turned
out to be that
force actually encompasses all of this
that force is engaged in
you know unfolding itself into something
that appeared to be an other but it's
really just force
and he goes on and says um
here we go um it essentially is a form
of the super session the
the elf right of the subsisting matters
or is essentially one
so this oneness since force is positive
as the
medium of the matters is now something
other than force which then has its
essence outside of itself right looks
like at first
we're doing this externalization and
force is becoming other than itself
but sense force must have necessity be
this oneness which is not yet positive
as being
this other approaches it soliciting it
to reflect itself
into itself that is force supersedes
its expression force over here
supersedes its expression by the very
fact
that all of this soliciting stuff itself
is also force
so he says the oneness and the form in
which it appeared as in other vanishes
force is this other itself so now
what are we being posed with we actually
have
do we have two different forces do we
just have force
in two different you know ways or two
different places there's this action of
soliciting that's going on
and the action of expression um these
these matters now are not that important
they're just sort of getting bound up
within it they're going to assume
an importance later on but now we're
going to be looking at the interplay
between force and force
what appears as an other and solicits
force both to expression and to return
into itself directly proves to be itself
force for the other shows itself to be
as much a universal medium as
a one and in such a way that each of
these forms at the same time appears
only as a vanishing moment
consequently force in that there is an
other for
it and it is for an other has
not yet altogether emerged from its
notion
there are at the same time two forces
present
the notion of both is no doubt the same
but it has gone forth from its unity
into a duality
instead of the antithesis remaining
entirely and essentially only a moment
it seems by itself direction into two
holy independent forces
to withdrawn from the controlling unity
we have now to see more closely the
implications
of this independence in the first place
the second force appears as the one that
solicits
and moreover in accordance with its
content as the universal medium
in relation to the force characterized
as the one solicited
but since the second force is
essentially an alternation of these two
moments
and is itself force it is likewise the
universal medium
only through its being solicited to be
such and similarly
to it is a negative unity that is it
solicits the retraction of force into
itself
only through its being solicited to do
so consequently this distinction too
which obtained between the two forces
one of which was supposed to be the
soliciting the other solicited
force is transformed into the same
reciprocal interchange
of the determinatenesses
section 138 is going to play out the
implications
of force being more than one
force having shown itself in the
previous section
to in its expression or its
externalizations
oyster to be
running into force itself and the
question is
can this be brought into a kind of unity
or do we have to think about there being
two distinct
not entirely separate but but certainly
distinguishable forces
and so as we're playing out the notion
of force we're going to see
that there is going to be what he calls
an antithesis happening
a direction a splitting a spalting
into each other so we start with with
force right
and we see that force has these two
aspects of return into itself
and expression of force i should
probably put an arrow here too because
you know the return into itself force
per se is what it is through its
expression
and what we find out is the other to
force
is an other force it's not something
radically different in that it has
nothing in common
or is not of the same genre or or
type as as force
but it's not the same force and hegel
talks about
this other force as essentially doing
two things
one is that it offers a
universal medium to the other
force that the original force it offers
the universal medium
in which this expression of force can
occur and what's the universal medium of
those different moments those different
you know
independent matters all that sort of
stuff there there has to be something
for force to be exercised upon
in order for there to be an expression
of force
but what we're seeing here is is what
force is being
externalized into outered into
you know projected onto is itself
something dynamic as well it's not
something purely static a
matter that just sits there and accepts
whatever comes its way
in part because this other force
solicits
this very set of actions of the
expression of force and the return
into itself out of expression
on the part of the original force
and this soliciting action
is something that this other force is
contributing you might say that
is the action of this
other force so what's the upshot of this
he says
um there's two forces present the notion
of both is no doubt the same
right so we have the same basic notion
of force
but it's gone forth from its unity into
a duality
there has been a splitting
and that splitting has gotten us to the
point of an
antithesis between two different forces
force has not turned out to be the
simple
idea or concept or reality
the not the simple notion that we wanted
it to be it turns out that it's notion
when we explore it is actually
more complex and reflexively complex
because it's force that's affecting
force in this case
so he says we now have to see what the
implications are
of this independence of these two forces
from each other
so what is it he says well in the first
place the second force appears as the
one that
solicits in accordance with its content
as the universal medium in relation to
the force characterizes the ones so
listen okay so so far we're so good
we already knew that we already got to
that point what further
what uh other thing do we add to this he
says
since the second force is essentially an
alternation of these two moments and is
itself
force it is likewise the universal
medium only through being
solicited to be such now
what are these two moments there's two
different ways we could read that
maybe the other force is the two
different moments of soliciting and
offering a universal medium
another way of thinking about it is this
other force has the same structure
of a return into itself force per
se and the expression of the force in
itself over here where hegel is going
with this
is that this entire action or set of
actions
of soliciting and offering a universal
medium
occurs precisely because this force
itself
solicits it so you've got two different
forces
neither one of which is the receptive
passive um you know suggesting hey let's
do this
kind of force they're both in an
interplay together
which one came first well you know
perhaps neither one as we're working
through it dialectically we find out
that there's a reciprocity
here that we didn't understand before
this
so he says the second force is
a universal medium only through its
being solicited to be such
because of this it's also a negative
unity it solicits the retraction of
force
into itself so now we have
force per se you know
in itself over here just as much as we
did over here
per se um
you might say the chalkboard solicits me
to misspell things
right it offers me that possibility and
the hegel
gets me so worked up that i you know
leave out letters that i should be
putting in there
in the expression in the externalization
so
going on with this he says um it also
solicits the retraction of force into
itself only through its being solicited
to do so
so this distinction which obtained
between the two forces one which was
supposed to be the soliciting force this
this other force over here
uh the other the solicited force is
transformed into the same
reciprocal interchange of the
determinatenesses
what does that big fancy phrase at the
end mean it means that these two forces
are actually in a state of
sort of mirroring with each other
there's a reciprocity there
both forces are soliciting the other
force to be
what it is neither force can be what it
is
without the contribution without the
interchange
with the other force so you don't get
one force
without the other you can't you can
strip them away from each other at an
abstraction
or your imagination but if what we're
trying to attend here to
here through phenomenology is the
reality of these things
is interconnected then we can't think
the two
forces apart from each other without
ceasing to actually think those two
forces and just
and to think something that's that's
less real less less dynamic less
dialectical so where are we going to go
from here
now we're going to look at how two
reciprocal forces connect with each
other
the interplay of the two forces thus
consists in their being determined as
mutually opposed in their being for one
another in this determination
and in the absolute immediate
alternation of the determinations
it consists that is in a transition
through which alone these determinations
are in which the forces seem to make an
independent appearance the soliciting
force for example is posited as a
universal medium and the one solicited
on the other hand
as force driven back into itself but the
former is a universal medium
only through the other being force that
is driven back into itself
or it is really the latter that is the
soliciting force for the other
and is what makes it a medium the first
force has its determinateness
only through the other and solicits only
insofar as the other solicits it to be a
soliciting force
and just as directly it loses the
determinateness given to it
for this passes over or rather has
already passed over
to the other the external soliciting
force appears as a universal medium
but only through its having been
solicited by the other force to do so
but this means that the latter gives it
that character and
is really itself essentially a universal
medium it gives us listening forces
character
just because this other determination is
essential to it
that is because this really is its own
self
section 139 begins by telling us three
important things about these
two forces that have been placed into
relation with each other
one is that this is a relation of mutual
opposition to each other they are
opposed just as much as they are
connected with each other
another is that each one has its being
for the other so the mutual opposition
we can represent by you know putting an
arrow with
things on both ends with both of these
having its being for the other means
that it's lacking its substantiality
that it wants to have
because in a certain way it's
conditioned by that other
then we can also talk about an
alternation
that is taking place between the two
forces
and the the first way of understanding
this alternation is going to get played
out in this passage
but we're going to see this happening
through a number of the other paragraphs
yet to come
so what's going on here he says
we've got two forces uh we have a a
force over here which we can think of in
a certain way as the passive force
and this as being the active force why
because this one is doing the soliciting
which is kind of an activity right it's
an activity behind the scenes
and this one is the force that is being
solicited
so this is really offering the universal
medium
in which the first force or the force on
this side at least can play itself out
because neither one of them is really
first they should have
you know avoided the first language
right there it's offering a universal
medium in which this force can
express itself in in which it can
externalize itself in which
it can actually do something change
things determine
matters and over here we have force that
is driven back
into itself so we have force that isn't
you know laying all of its cards on the
table
but keeping something in reserve even
while it expresses
so what we seem to have here
are you know two forces
one of which is seeming to do the main
activity
but it's really doing so because it's
being conditioned to do so
by the solicitation of the other
now it gets a little bit more tricky
hegel is going to say
that's not all that's happening he says
the soliciting force is posited as a
universal medium the one solicited as
force driven back into itself
but the former is a universal medium
only through the other being force
that's driven back into itself
it can only offer itself as a universal
medium
if you actually have some sort of force
that can play itself out that can
unfold itself within it so it says
it's really the latter that is the
soliciting force for the other
so that's really key
this force over here is actually
soliciting
the force that we think is the
soliciting force
which actually is a soliciting force
it's just that solid
solicitation now said solid station but
solicitation
is happening on both sides it's being
solicited
to solicit there's a reciprocity
a mirroring involved here a iteration
of reflexivity so he he goes on and he
says
um the first force is determinant is
only through the other it's
only determined in what it is through
its other
and it solicits only in so far as the
other solicits it to be a soliciting
force
and just as directly it loses the
determinateness given it
so that's actually passing over to the
side of the other force
where we thought determination or you
know
getting to decide things or or being the
most important part of things
was turns out to have been relocated
over here
and why is that the case well
in part because this force over here in
so far as it is soliciting
is itself really a universal medium as
well
for this force here doing the
solicitation and there's this back and
forth that's happening
this may take a little bit to to to
grasp as you're reading through it
but you know think about how these
things play themselves out it might be
very helpful
to think about this in terms of
conversational dynamics
rather than in terms of abstract forces
about people
talking to each other maybe having an
argument and deciding who actually
started the argument
you know that could be the solicitation
going on here
in any case what we have is the
development of this reciprocity
where now what what seem to be just
doing the soliciting to be a universal
medium
turns out to be very much like the force
on the other side